من اوكرانيا ينضم الينا او بالاحلام
اللفيف تحديدا الاستاذ المساعد في جامعه
كافل للغات ماكولا باستون مرحبا واهلا بيك
استاذ ماكولا كما تفضلت وسالت مفادنا همم
عن همم الوقائع او المعلومات الاوليه التي
نعلمها عن حادثه تحطم المروحيه يعني هل
تبين حتى الساعه ما اذا كان مجرد حدث عربي
ام انه همم هجوم مفطعه او همم على
المروحيه يعني ما هي المعلومات التي
نعرفها حتى الساعه من جانب الحكومه
الاوكرانيه
صباح الخير نعم هذا من اخر الاخبار سقوط
مروحيه وكان علاماتها وزير الداخليه
والنايبه مسؤولين من الوزاره
[موسيقى]
طبعا حتى الان
لاين الحكومه
كيف تفاصيل همم
هل كانت هذه همم عمليه عمليه هجونيه
ارهابيه او حادث فقط همم تعملوا لجنه
تحقيقيه حاليا وهمم من المفترض مقدمه خلال
اليوم او خلال يومين همم تقريبا اوليه همم
الحديث
على اتي حال همم هذه خساره كبيره في همم
لدوله في حاله الحرب قتل همم وزير الخارج
الداخليه
قد يؤثر على سياسه
استقرار همم
[موسيقى]